we're joined by Eric Bates he's the
editor at New Republic Eric good morning
good morning what an extraordinary week
what do you think in the end the impact
of the the Comey firing is is having on
the White House at this point well I
think it's to begin with a huge
distraction they have a big agenda it's
hard to concentrate on that when you've
got all this other noise going on I
don't think it's caused him a lot of
support among Republicans so far because
they've had to circle the wagons they
don't have any choice you know they were
all in on him at this point but it is
kind of metastasizing into a new
narrative and that could be really
problematic obviously the idea that
possibly there are secret recordings has
grabbed the headlines and there's been
no further explanation what do you make
of this it's hard to know I mean Trump
has a history of just making things up
and throwing them out there this from
the guy who said he was being taped by
Obama so whether he threw that out there
just as a hand grenade or not but I do
think Donald Trump is perhaps the only
person in the world who could whose
takeaway from Watergate could have been
tape recordings that's a good idea
meanwhile where does the Russia
investigation go at this point I mean
you have a president who's clearly upset
about the Russia investigation he calls
it a made-up story but at the same time
the firing in fact turned cast more
light on the whole story sure I mean
from that sense the timing was horrible
I don't think Trump thinks in that way
he was in thinking is this going to make
it worse or better
but now the spotlights really going to
be on is there any sort of interference
any sort of foot dragging on that
there's going to be so much more
attention to it now than there was
before and investigation is there to
answer the question was anything done
wrong and that's got to happen in a way
now that's just rigorous and thorough
you mentioned before everything sort of
hanging out there and obviously the
investigation as well president Trump
heads to the Middle East for his first
foreign visit how does this follow him
there
I think his hope is that this is going
to be a big distraction that he's going
to change the channel that Trump in the
Holy Land is somehow going to take over
the narrative but I doesn't feel to me
like this one's going to go away and we
really believe that that will stop
talking about the other things in the
media and that suddenly the focus will
all be on the middle
I think one of the reasons he did the
firing is because he as an entertainer
and as a reality show person knows how
to change the narrative he thinks when
when it starts going the way you don't
like just shift the focus so I think now
whether this is going to be big enough
for ratings wise to shift the focus
we'll see well before the focus was
shifted we were talking about healthcare
and the tax agenda what does this mean
for for the president's agenda at this
point well I think it makes it very hard
even though the Republicans have circled
the wagons it's going to make it harder
and harder for them to get the job done
on some of those big things where it
really is going to come down to a few
votes where he needs to peel people off
where he needs people feeling
comfortable that they can come with them
and comfort isn't exactly the word that
we've had in the past week I think it's
going to make it very difficult for a
lot of people to see him as an ally you
know you mentioned that he hasn't lost
the support in some of that base what
needs to happen for that possibly to
happen that's been the question from the
beginning I mean everybody has thought
that there's some political norm that
Trump will violate that will be his
undoing and from the moment he came down
the escalator and called Mexicans
rapists and announcing his presidency
that has not been the case so that's
really the question is there any norm
that can violate given that violating
political norms is his entire brand Eric
Bates thank you we appreciate the
insight